Hello everyone. Welcome to a new episode of The
Dissenter. I'm your host, as always, Ricardo Lops, and
today I'm joined by Amy Elves. She's the host
of the Breaking Down Patriarchy podcast and YouTube channel,
and of course I will be linking it in
the description. And today we're going to talk about
Feminism, patriarchy, capitalism and colonialism, the manosphere, whether feminism
includes boys and men and other related topics. So
Amy, welcome to the show. It's a big pleasure
to have everyone. I've been looking forward to this
conversation, so.
Me too. Thanks for having me.
OK, so look, um, I would like to ask
you first, what is feminism? I mean, not because,
I mean, I also consider myself a feminist, but
it's not that I consider this question to be
extremely relevant also because as we're going to talk
about here, there are different kinds of feminism, but
because Particularly for people who do not, who are
not very much into feminism, who are not very
versed on feminism, or do not identify as feminists
or even oppose it, uh, I mean, sometimes people
demand that we, uh, give a definition of feminism.
So how would you define it? And do you
think that, uh, as I was alluding to, we
really need the universal definition of feminism or not?
Yes, definitely we do. And in fact, I usually
do start whenever I speak at a conference, or
just have a conversation with someone where I sense
that maybe we're not on the same page. I
always do start with the definition, and I really
recommend doing that, um, because I think sometimes having
a conversation about topics that can be controversial or
emotional. Um, SOMETIMES you end up having the frustrating
feeling that you're just talking past each other, and
establishing a common definition, a working definition, helps that
a lot. So, um, yes, people can define feminism
differently. Um, SO, I think, um, a really good
strategy is to just go to the dictionary and
say, like, let's just agree that it means what
the dictionary says it means. And if you look
at any, you know, standard English language dictionary, the,
the definition of feminism, I I actually wrote it
down. I went to, this is just the Merriam-Webster
Dictionary, which is pretty standard in America. It says,
feminism is belief in and advocacy for the political,
economic, and social equality of the sexes, expressed especially
through organized activity on behalf of women's rights and
interests. So, I just think it's important to point
out that feminism, and, and in any dictionary you
look at, it will say essentially that, that feminism
is the effort toward the equality of the genders.
There's no definition you'll ever read anywhere, official definition
that says that feminism, um, has the goal of
women ruling over men. The goal is equality. And
then implied in that is the understanding that the
genders aren't equal now, and so feminism is the
work required to to equalize opportunity for the genders.
Yeah, there's, there's one thing that you mentioned there
that's really important, I think, for people to keep
in mind that feminism is really not about women
ruling over men or women just acquiring all positions
of power and then submitting them to them. Also
because people have this idea that, OK, so even
though nowadays, I mean after colonialism and all of
that European colonial. COLONIALISM, there's barely any societies out
there that we could label as matriarchal, but the
few ones that we can still find out there,
I mean, even those, they are not called matriarchal
because women rule over men. They are called matriarchal
just because women have more political power, even not
necessarily even more political. Political power than men, but
they have more of a say than in patriarchal
societies, and they, it's easier for them to, for
example, I'm remembering the, in the Musuo society in
China, it's in the, in the society in India
whose name I'm missing right now, uh, it's easier
for women to just divorce men and women, and
there's met. Liarity in some of those societies, so
inheritance is passed through the maternal line instead of
the paternal line and all and and different other
sorts of practices and norms that people have in
those societies, but it's really not about women reversing
the roles and submitting men,
right? Correct, yeah, that's exactly right.
Yeah, so, but I mean one thing that many
times really confuses people, and I think it's also
important for us to clarify here is that there's
not one single kind of feminism. There are multiple
types of feminism out there. There's, for example, liberal
feminism within liberal feminism. There's specifically white feminism. There's
red. Radical feminism within radical feminism you can find
for example gender critical feminists. There's Marxist slash socialist
feminism, intersectional feminism. I mean, what do you make
of the different types of feminism out there? I
mean, how do you think we should deal with
that diversity within feminism?
Yeah, so I would say, um, backing up, maybe
I'll kind of paint a picture, and then that
will make the answer um clear. Patriarchy, as all
social systems developed over a long period of time,
um, in differently in different ways, but if you
think of patriarchy as having developed kind of like,
um, a city. So if you picture Long, long,
long, long ago, when there's just open space, there's
just an open field, humans haven't settled in a,
in a place yet. You have infinite options of
how you want to create a, a settlement, a
city, right? At some point, somebody decides, OK, let's
lay foundations of a building, and they put the
foundations down, and they build a structure, and, and
then that, it can grow and grow, and then
you end up with, with a town, right? That
has streets and, and buildings. And then typically what
happens is, especially if you build foundations with stone,
rather than digging up the foundations to, to, you
know, create new places in your city, you're just
gonna build on top of the foundations you've already
laid, right? And so if you go to a,
an old, old city, it, like in Portugal where
you live, um, you have, uh, maybe like the
medieval section of a city where the streets are
really, really narrow, right? And maybe some of the
buildings are not earthquake-safe, or they have, you know,
trouble with the electrical or the plumbing because they're
so old. If we were to build a city,
Now, we would build it wider to accommodate for
cars, and we could, we would build it, you
know, with, with the most modern technology to serve
the needs of the people, right? But what happens
is those cities are just kind of like built
on old, old, old ideas. You don't even remember
who, who started it, and patriarchy is the same
way, you know, at some point, somebody had the
idea that men would men's role would be this,
women's role would be this, they hand it down
to their children, it gets handed down to their
children, just taken for granted, and we, we find
ourselves living in this narrow, restrictive ideology. And so,
the question is, with each generation that we're like,
oh, shoot, what did I inherit from like, generations
past? What did I inherit? OK, what am I
gonna do about it? And different people will have
different ideas of what to do about it. And
if you think about the word radical, so radical
feminism, the word radical just means from the root,
right? So, a radical feminist looks at the city
plan that we've inherited and says, the whole thing's
corrupt. It doesn't serve the needs of the people
living in this structure. We need to bulldoze the
city and route, like, dig up the foundations and
start over. And so, that's really, technically, that's what
radical feminism is. It means take out the foundations,
take it out at the root. That's what radical
feminism means. If you look at liberal feminism, another
way of describing liberal feminism is just, it's reform
of feminism. So, they, they would be more apt
to say, we're not gonna undo the foundations, maybe
it won't work, maybe just nobody will get on
board to do this, it's just not practical, or
maybe we don't even want to do that, because
there are good things about the city. But what
we're going to do instead is, let's just work
with the structure we have. We'll retrofit for earthquakes,
we'll repaint and recarpet the apartment we live in,
to make it better. Like, we're, we'll make improvements
within the system. So, a reform or or liberal
feminism will say, like, OK, let's make sure that
within our system, Women are paid equally for equal
work. Let's make sure that women can vote, right?
Let's make sure that women have reproductive rights, but
we're working within the system we have. Um, AND
then you mentioned intersectional feminism. Um, AND that is
just like the definition of that is just acknowledging
and recognizing that different women have different experiences. It's
not just about gender, but it, but the, the
way that a woman moves through her life in
the world will, will be determined by race and
class and ability and social status, all kinds of
other factors, where I, as a white woman who
um has had a lot of opportunity and financial
stability in my life, I will be having a
very different um life experience than a friend of
mine even who even goes to the same university
as I do and lives in the same place,
but is black, or has a disability, or there's
just a lot of different layers to human experience
and um The intersectional feminism is really, really important,
I think, in every conversation, because we have a
history, unfortunately, in the, you know, I'll just speak
in the United States because that's what I'm most
familiar with, but of white feminists advocating for the
rights of quote unquote, women, but being really blind
to the needs of, of all women and thinking
that their needs as elite. Um, WHITE women was
speaking for all women when it wasn't, and, and
white women being actually very racist and excluding women
of color from the rights that they wanted for
themselves. And so, I'm, I'm very glad that you
brought up intersectionality at the very beginning of the
episode, because that has to be a part of
every conversation to make sure that we're advocating for
the rights of all women and not just a
few. Those are just a few any of the
definitions that you wanted.
Yeah, sure, and I mean, uh, when it comes
to, for example, uh, having an intersectional attitude to
things, I mean there are people who decide to
not label themselves as feminists or not associate themselves
with the feminist. MOVEMENT based on one critique that
they have of it and that actually for the
most part, or at least historically for the most
part we have to take seriously there is the
fact that for most of the history of the
feminist movement. Very unfortunately, if people or women who
are part of uh or have minority identities have
been for the most part excluded, right? I mean
that's a critique that we have to take seriously.
That's right, definitely. And um some of my, my
black feminist, or, well, my black friends and colleagues
would say they don't identify with the word feminist,
they prefer the term womanist, which was coined by
Alice Walker. People might know Alice Walker is the
author of The Color Purple, and um she was
writing, you know, in the, the 70s and 80s
and seeing That at the time, the, the application
of feminism was really, it was a white woman's
project that was very exclusive, and so, and also
the perception at that time also, and I think
it's true, it was very white, but it was
she, Alice Walker, perceived it as being anti-men. And
her view of womanism was uh with love toward
men, inclusion of black men in the project of
egalitarianism, and so her term womanism was about lifting
up everyone, not being anti-men, and also being, um,
yeah, inclusive of all races, and so, I mean,
womanism is definitely a term and a project that
I can get behind. I, I think lately there
has been more of an effort, instead of saying
I'm not a feminist, instead to expand and ensure
that our, our feminist work is inclusive, is not
anti-men, is, you know, um, Universal in its, in
its goals of elevating and ensuring the rights of
everybody. But I can understand why a person wouldn't
want to be associated with feminism because of those
pain points historically, for sure.
Right, so, but I mean, how, how should people,
particularly people who are not very familiar with feminist,
er think about the fact that feminism has all
of these different branches. I mean, also because there
are particular questions where some of these branches disagree
on and there are really big. WAYS of looking
at society more generally where they are diametrically opposed.
So for example, the liberal feminists tend to be,
if not completely diametrically opposed, very close to that
when it compared to Marxist or socialist feminists. I
mean, liberal feminists tend to very much support the
capitalist system and just say. That, OK, at a
certain point in history we've removed the barriers for
women, and now there's just a meritocracy out there.
And as long as women are able and they
focus a lot on choice, right, as long as
people are women specifically are able to make the
choices that they want, whatever outcomes we have, that's
just, I mean. RESPONSIBILITY, their fault, whatever, because we've
removed the obstacles and on the other end of
the spectrum, Marxist or socialist feminists would say, yeah,
that's not right because we have an oppressive economic
system operating and there's and people come from different
classes and so the opportunities from the get-go are.
Some people are excluded from a lot of those
opportunities that, for example, upper class rich people have.
I mean, people at the bottom don't really have
those opportunities. And then, for example, if we want
to add intersectional feminism to that, we can also
say, yeah, OK, so people with certain kinds of
identities, I don't know, black women, trans women. Uh,
LESBIAN women also are excluded for some of those
opportunities and so they don't really start from the
same point. Uh, AND for example, and just to
give another example because there are many out there,
of course, but, uh, radical feminists, uh, some of
them, uh, I'm, I'm not sure if it's really
all of them, but at least some of them
stand in opposition. To sex work, but then there
are feminists who defend the sex work as an
activity and sex workers themselves, and I mean we
could use labels here like sex negative and sex
positive. Some people use those labels. So I mean,
how should people make sense of all of these
apparent contradictions within feminism?
I think the first step is to recognize that
the enemy is not other feminists, but the enemy
is the system, and um, I mean, I do
like the analogy. I find, I do find it
useful to, to return to that metaphor of the
foundations that were laid so many thousands of years
ago. I mean, prehistory is when patriarchy started, and
we can talk about that a little later if
you want to. PATRIARCHY started, but nobody alive right
now is at fault for the systems that we
inherited. Not men either, and not, and so, we,
we all are looking around and saying, like, well,
what a mess, you know, what a mess our
ancestors handed to us. And so, having that, uh,
remembering that, hopefully can give us compassion and kind
of, like, Understanding of why different people would have
different ideas about what to do about it, about
how to deconstruct the things that are harming and
what to build. Also, remembering that patriarchy hurts people
deeply and in different ways. And my experience, for
example, growing up in um a very conservative, high-demand
patriarchal religion, my pain points will be acute, very
acute for me. And, and very different from a
person that grew up, you know, in a different,
uh, a different context, a different cultural context. They
might not have those religious wounds, but they might
have, you know, financial wounds, or see that everybody
will experience it differently. And so, I do think
that it's important to remember. That we're all suffering
from this, and we all, we all, you know,
incur damage, but in different ways, so that we
can be patient with each other, and my, um,
strategy is to really listen if I, if I
am encountering a feminist who sees it differently and
thinks, like, you're wrong. I really want to, like,
pause and say, tell me about what the pain
points have been for you. What, what are the
harms that you've experienced in your life, in your
family, in your workplace, in your faith community, whatever
it is, and try to understand where that person
is coming from and see, like, oh, OK, I
might still not agree. But I can at least
see where the person is coming from and see
their pain points, and then from there, I mean,
getting a bunch of people to work together, we
all know this, like trying to have a democracy,
it's the only way, but it's messy, it's not
easy, but if we can come together, really listen
to each other, and then try to see, like,
OK, now that we kind of understand where we're
coming from, are there any common denominators here of,
like, OK, we can all get behind. This certain
cause, we could all work together on this, and
that's, that's my strategy also is just like an
incremental next step in what whatever you're doing, whether
it's political, if you want to change a law,
or whether it is in your faith community, if
you want women to be able to be ordained,
or whatever it is, or if you want trans
people to have more rights than they have. Now?
Like, what's the next increment? How can we get
people on board? I think people are best brought
on board through bridge building and heart to heart
conversations of, of trying to understand and trying to
move things forward in a way that benefits people.
So, That's one of my, that's one of my
answers. Uh, IT, it makes sense. People would see
it differently. Let's try to talk to each other
and understand each other, and then see if we
can find. A couple of things that we can
all agree to work toward. And then I, I'll
say one more thing, and that is, um, this
is kind of a personal thing too, where if
there really is a difference, I, I, I'll, I'll,
I'll give you an, uh, an example that I
have a good friend right now, whose approach in
the work that she's doing, I actually kind of
disagree with it. I think it's in certain ways,
Kind of backfires cause it, it's more anti antagonistic
and aggressive. Um, I'd If I'm honest, I just
think like, I wish you wouldn't do that, but
at the end of the day, I know what
my contribution is during my short lifetime on this
earth. I'm very clear about what my contribution is,
but I, I am, I have to trust also
that she's being really thoughtful and intentional about what
she wants her contribution to be. And we don't
all need to be the same. Some people do,
I, like I said, I'm a bridge builder, and
I'm a person who wants to get people on
board with their hearts. But there are people who
need to be the battering ram up on the,
the, the castle fortress, right? And, and use force
to, to bang. Down a wall sometimes. That's not
my strength. That's not what I'm called to do.
I know what I'm called to do, but maybe
my friend really is. That's her life purpose, and
she's going to use her head to, to knock
down a door, then I have to trust that,
that, that all the voices are needed, and even
if they're different from each other.
Yeah, me personally, I mean, I don't even care
much about, for example, labeling myself. I mean, apart
from using the broader label of feminist, I mean,
whether I'm a OK, so maybe if people asked
me, I would say, OK, so I'm a sort
of a socialist intersectional feminist. Something like that if
people really forced me to to pick a label,
but I mean apart from that, er I, I
think that it's important also for feminists to be
willing to criticize attitudes within the movement. So for
example, for me, uh, I don't have much patience
to be very honest for er things. Like excluding
or exclusionary attitudes toward trans people, for example, or
exclusionary attitudes toward sex workers, and I mean anything
that's exclusionary or that tries to put all responsibility
on individuals to improve their own condition or things
like that. I mean, but But apart from that,
I mean, I don't even care really that much
about the labels. For me, it's more important to
really talk about the ideas and what we want
for society.
Yeah, thanks for saying that. And if I can
add, because I, I, as I just spoke about
like tolerance and building bridges and heart to heart,
and I do believe that, but I do have
to say too, Um, I agree with you. There
are, that doesn't mean that I'm tolerant of a
feminist who has racist attitudes or is cruel toward
trans people. I have absolutely no tolerance for that.
I would just say, if I encounter them, I
find that they're more likely to be receptive. If
I can have a conversation and say, like, where
are you coming from? But my goal is not
to, to say like, oh, I see. Like, you're
a racist for this reason, so that's OK. We
can have you, no, no, no, absolutely not. There's
no tolerance for that. But if we can talk,
sometimes that's a way to, to help a person
change their heart and become more inclusive. So, I
wanted to clarify that,
yeah. No, yeah, yeah, of course. So, another thing,
uh, another basic term here is patriarchy, because sometimes
people make it seem particularly critics of feminism that
patriarchy is just a diffused term. It doesn't really
mean anything concrete, and sometimes people start saying, oh
yeah, you're talking about men being in power, and
of course it's not really necessarily about men. Being
in power, but we're going to talk about that.
But yeah, but there's also tons of homeless men.
There's also tons of poor men out there, also
tons of men who suffer from addiction, mental illness,
and all kinds of different issues, men who are
underpaid as well because of the types of work
they do and things like that. And, and nowadays
we see more and more women in politics, in
leadership roles, so. PATRIARCHY, I mean, what are you
talking about? So, I mean, how, how does it,
what is your definition if you have one, of
course, of patriarchy, and in what ways would you
say it manifests socially and politically?
Yeah, yeah, again, just going to the dictionary is
useful. So patriarchy, the etymology, you can hear what
it means in the word, right, patri, father, and
archy is a governing system just like monarchy, monoarchy,
one person ruling. Um, OR anarchy, no one ruling
the, the ruling system, and so patriarchy, um, means
father rule, and the way it's practiced is that
men do have status, um, over women in society.
And so there's, you know, if you look historically,
I think Any reasonable person could look at the
history of, especially the Western world, right, and see
that it has historically been a patriarchy, where men
had had status and privilege over women. Um, It's,
it's easier to see in certain contexts, and again,
because I came from a, a very conservative patriarchal
religion, I, I come from the Mormon faith, and
because in that religion, um, only men can be
ordained to priesthood, and so all Women are presided
over by men in the home, in the structure,
only men can perform ordinances, and so, it's a
very, very clear and overt patriarchy. Catholicism is the
same, right? If you look at a picture of,
um, of Catholic leaders, it's just 100% men, and
those men do not allow women, um, into leadership
positions, so women can't, don't have voting power, basically
to make decisions for their own lives. Yeah, here,
here in Portugal we are a majority Catholic country
and yeah, what you're saying there is 100% true.
I mean we only have, it's all men, priests,
men, bishops, the Pope is a man as well.
I mean, no woman, at least for now, can
hold. One of those positions.
Yeah, right. And so that those are great examples
of, like, de jure patriarchy, like, it's encoded in
the law of the of the system that women
cannot be leaders. So, that's very easy. There's pros
and cons, right? In one, in one sense, it's
hard to combat that kind of patriarchy because it's
so enshrined. But in, on, in another sense, it's,
it's nice because you can see it. It's right
out there where you, where you know exactly the
battle that you have to fight, and nobody's pretending
it's otherwise. A de facto patriarchy, where it's not
encoded in law anymore, is a little trickier. And
one example of that in the United States, if
you, just like I just said, if you look
at, like, literally a photograph of, like, all the
popes, or, like, paintings, I guess, all the popes
from, you know, the beginning till now, you just
see it's all men. Um, IF you look at
all of the presidents of the United States since
our first president in the 18th century, It's literally
all men, but you can go through, like, um,
the historical timeline and see, like, well, this is
de jure, women were not allowed to vote, they
weren't allowed to hold office until, you know, a
certain year, you can see like, oh, well, from
that to that. Then it wasn't encoded in law
anymore, and yet, there are still no women. We've
literally never had a woman president. We just won't
elect one. Americans just won't entrust women with leadership.
So, you can say it's not a patriarchy anymore
because there's no laws preventing women from becoming president.
It's not in our laws anymore. It's in our
culture, it's in our mental attitudes, it's in individual
people's minds still, and that can last for hundreds
of years longer, even after you change the laws,
patriarchy in the culture takes a really, really, really
long time, and sometimes it, I mean, It's, it's
hard to know how to fight those battles because
people can say, like, I don't know what you're
talking about. We're not prejudiced against women, and yet,
and yet they are. And so, that's, that's one
way of thinking about it. Another thing is that,
to your point, and this is really true, like
we were talking about with intersectional. Um, FEMINISM, there
are just so much, there's so much complexity that
goes into people's lives, and just like I said
earlier that I may encounter a lot of sexism
as a woman, but I never encounter sexism plus
racism, or sexism plus ableism or whatever. There are
things I don't encounter. When I look at one
of my very best friends is a black gay
man. And so, it just depends what metric you're
looking at about, like, which of, how, how do
we move through the world and what barriers, what
hurdles do we encounter. He's a man, I'm a
woman. We both come from Mormonism, so he had
status over me as a man. If he hadn't
been gay and we had gotten married, he would
have had status over me, and, and, um, presiding
power over me in our marriage. But, in a
lot of the pla in a lot of places
that we go, because I'm white and he's black,
I have status over him, or because I'm straight
and he's gay. I have privilege that he doesn't
have, and he encounters cruel cruelty that I never
will, because of those, those things. And so, they
don't cancel each other out, but it's just really,
it is important to acknowledge. Men can have very,
very hard lives. Men who, who experience poverty, Men
who have disabilities, they will have on maybe on,
on balance, a a more difficult time than I
will. But with that said, women also have disabilities
and encounter poverty, and have, you know, if they're
women of color, they encounter racism, they experience all
of those things, and also sexism. That men will
never experience. And there are areas of life where,
let's say in a, I come back to religion
because it's so easy to see there. Let's say
that it's, you know, uh, a man who is,
you know, maybe impoverished and doesn't have very many
opportunities in the world, and other men kind of
rule over him in the world, he can still
go home. And have status over his wife at
home, and maybe beat his wife at home, and
people will look the other way. So he does
have status over the women in his life, even
though he may, you know, go to out in
the world, he may be oppressed, truly, and, and
might be oppressed and might have a very difficult
life, he does have status over women in certain
areas because of patriarchy.
Yeah, that's one of the areas why I also
tend to include intersectional feminism in my view and
not really just be. I mean constrained to, I,
I don't even look at it as a constraint
necessarily, but limited to a socialist view of things
because very unfortunately many times people who are socialists,
communists, Marxists tend to have Very class reductionist view
of things and they are not very open to
including social categories apart from a class and apart
from the proletariat versus the bourgeoisie and things like
that. So, you know, it's, it's very unfortunate, but
sometimes that happens.
It does, and I will say that it is
important. I would say like fewer Americans that I
know, maybe this is just depends on where we
live, but the people I know. I would say
don't take a Marxist view of gender issues enough,
and maybe that's because, like, Americans are, like, so
anti-communist in general, so they're like, terrified of socialism.
Um, I have found a lot of really valuable
cri critique in Marxist feminism. Because class is such
a huge part of it, and it is really
important, I think, for feminists to remember, for especially
women of means, women who do have financial ease
in their life. To remember to take seriously the
claims that men make when they say, like, I
mean, for example, I'll hear women talking about, like,
well, men have always been allowed to work outside
the home, which has enabled them to, you know,
achieve their potential, acquire financial independence and responsibility, or,
and, um, and freedom, and that's true for a
lot of men, some men, But not a man
who's like trapped in a, in an exploitative, oppressive
job or works in a factory, and so it's
really, really important, I think, also to remember
that or or or even, sorry for interrupting, or
even if we go further back in time and
talk about feudalism, I mean men and women were
working both in the fields, I mean, producing food
that most of it would go to the nobles.
Exactly, exactly. That's so important to remember. And it's,
and, and therefore, it's also important to remember that
the way patriarchy has always worked, is not that
every man has privileges and status in an easy
life. It's that a few men have status and
power over All the other men for various reasons,
and they have status and power over all the
women because they're women, right? But that, that not
all men are able to have, yeah, easy lives
in patriarchy. That's certainly true. So, yeah.
But, uh, I mean, do we know exactly how
and when patriarchy originated and how it spread through
the globe? I mean, At least from my conversations
with some anthropologists, the understanding I have is that
possibly the best theory out there is that patriarchy
came with societies becoming more hierarchical, and that came
from societies adopting a more sedentary lifestyle based on
agriculture, and agriculture allowed for the accumulation of Resources
and then people who basically took over certain social
institutions held more power over those resources, and then
a patriarchal system was created around that social structure
so or within that social structure and then I
mean the best understanding I have about how it
spread through the globe was pretty much through those
societies. Expanding through conquest and then even more so
through European colonial colonialism, which basically encompassed almost the
entire world, right? That is that, is that the
same understanding you have of it or it
is, yeah, for sure, yeah, that's a really good
summary. I don't know if you want me to
go back and go into a little bit more
detail.
Yes, please go ahead. Yes.
Yeah, but that was exactly the, that was the
um. A really concise and accurate summary. Uh, YEAH,
if you go back, I mean, obviously, anything that
happened before we have written records, people are just
guessing based on, you know, archaeological digs. They're making
guesses based on, well, it looks like, you know,
these sleeping areas seem to belong to women cause
they're slightly smaller, and so it looks like, oh,
these sleeping areas. It looks like the women stayed
and slept their whole lives in the same place,
but the men came to live with the women.
Oh, that looks like they're matrilocal. Looks like this
society, when you got married, you went and lived
with the wife's family, and that privileges the women
in that way. So, people making guesses like that,
based on it's just an example of how an
an archaeologist might look at a The remains of
a of a human settlement and make some guesses
about what was going on with gender, or you
can see if men and women, you know, based
on their, their bones, if they were eating equal
nourishment, right? That that says a lot about a
society. It says a lot about a society if
you see a man buried with a lot of
wealth, and many women that were sacrificed when he
was, was, was buried, that tells you a lot,
but if you don't have written records, Um, you're
making guesses. In the earliest written records, we have,
you know, some of the earliest laws, the Code
of Hammurabi, the Middle Assyrian laws, things that were
written down, and by the time humans were writing
their laws, patriarchy was already very, very established, very
encoded. Um, MALE violence against women was tolerated and
even, like, um, required in certain circumstances. For example,
if there was infidelity, if, uh, in, uh, I
believe this is the Code of Hammurabi, that if
there was infidelity, a man would be fined, a
woman would be stoned to death, you know, so,
just, you can tell that men have taken over,
and they've made, they've created an oppressive system for
women.
Uh, I mean, for, for example, the concept that
is a very modern concept that we have, uh,
a legal and moral concept of domestic violence is
very recent, correct.
Correct. And we, and we take it for granted,
and you just, it's just, um, it's kind of
a hideous thing that humans have done. Um, BUT,
but yes, but there is evidence before, before we
have those written laws, there is evidence that when
humans are hunter-gatherers, when they're nomadic, when they're following
animals primarily, and they're not, as you said, but
pre-agriculture, that lifestyle tends to be much more egalitarian.
I think it's worth noting, I think it's interesting
that hunter-gatherer, um, Groups of humans, it doesn't necessarily
mean that there isn't a gendered division of labor.
There often is a gendered division of labor, which,
in my view, maybe this is controversial, but it
makes sense if a woman is pregnant and breastfeeding
and taking care of babies, there will be a
period of her life where she has a, a
different role, a different contribution to the community. Though,
I will say, like, we have, like, I mean,
there's it's kind of, like, a common understanding that,
like, the men were the hunters and the women
were the gatherers, and that's not necessarily true. A
lot of, um, hunter-gatherer cultures, now, there's evidence that
women would hunt for actually a lot of their
lives. Um, BUT anyway, but even if there is
gender division of labor, that doesn't mean that it's
hierarchical, because if everybody agrees to it, and everybody
has equal decision-making power, you can Make whatever laws
you want for your group, and, and that's in
my view, that's completely,
yeah, you can, you can have sort of a
gender division of labor and even different gender roles,
but that doesn't necessarily translate into gender inequality.
Exactly, exactly. If you have equal decision making power
in your group, then whatever you decide is, in
my view, then that's, that's fine as long as
you have decision making power. So, anyway, yes, um,
nomadic and, and, um, hunter-gatherer societies, very egalitarian. And
then once agriculture started, um, as you said, with
the accumulation of wealth, you see all kinds of
hierarchy starting to form. That's when people started enslaving
other people, and men started viewing women as a
means of production. TO use a, a Marxist term,
right? Like, that they are the means to more
wealth. They can produce more heirs, and once you
start acquiring wealth, then men started wanting to make
sure that they were passing down that wealth to
their own children, and to their own sons, and
women became kind of, I mean, it's kind of
a crass way to put it, but breeders, basically,
to, to make more children, to, to accrue more
wealth toward particular men. Um, AND so that happened,
you see it happening all over the world at
different times because people developed agriculture at different times,
but when people develop agriculture, they start getting hierarchical,
including, um, including gender. Um, I would say too,
one thing, um, that's really, really important is that
once men started having more wealth, well, once humans
started having more wealth, the people in charge started
having more free time, and once you see a
group having more free time, they, they start writing,
they start making up, or they, and they start
writing their stories down. And this is where I'll
bring back the metaphor of like the foundations, and
then building on top of those foundations. This is
really critical because once men started to become scribes
and priests, then they started writing down what they
thought was important about their culture, their historical record,
their creation narrative, and then they were the ones
who got to they got to tell the story
about the genders, and then interpret that story about
the genders. And, for example, if you look at
the Hebrew Bible, It was written, I mean, they,
they, it claims to be writing about, like, the
creation of the world and the time of Abraham,
but it wasn't written until a few 100 years,
you know, before the common era, by an exclusively
male group of different priests, and there is a
lot of power in the person who gets to
write down, and this, you know, this is how
God, the Father, created. Adam, and then Adam had,
you know, stewardship over Eve. Whoever writes that story
has intent, amazing power, because then that's the foundation
that everybody builds on forever after that. So that's,
yeah, you get priests, you get kings, you get
scribes, and they, they have the power to create
the symbol systems that everyone believes in. And so
then you have women who are taught from the
time they're little girls. Because, you know, that's your
holy text, and that's your creation narrative. Oh, my
job is to be a support to the men.
I'm supposed to have babies. I'm supposed to do
what my dad tells me, and then do what
my husband tells me. And if it's, if it's
written, there's really, it makes it very, very hard
to argue against that. And also, they're writing down
the laws, the political laws, and, and granting or
denying. Women, you know, suffrage, women's participation in the
economy. So, I would say education, and, and men
keeping women out of education was one of the
most, um, effective oppressive tactics that men were able
to inquire and keep a hold of for literally
thousands of years. American women didn't get the right
to vote until 1920. That's just, it's absurd. It's
an absurdly long time that women had absolutely No,
rights to, um, to change the laws because they,
they didn't have the right to vote. And then,
to your point, um, like you said, how did
they spread? For example, where I live in North
America, the indigenous, um, communities that lived in North,
Central and South America, huge diversity. And some of
them, People like to talk about, you know, the
Americas as being purely matriarchal, and that's, that's not
true. There's huge diversity. Some were on a, on
a scale of patriarchal to matriarchal. They were everywhere
along that continuum of, you know, egalitarian in the
middle, but in general, much more egalitarian than the.
Yeah, yeah, the idea here is not just saying
that, oh, those societies. We just perfectly equal and
none of them were patriarchal at all. It's just
to say that basically European colonization uniformized or homogenized,
let's say, uh, societies across the world in terms
of bringing in terms of making them whole, all
hierarchical and patriarchal.
Yeah, exactly, exactly. So wherever they were on the
continuum, once, once the colonizers came. They brought Catholicism,
they brought capitalism, they brought all of those systems
that, that did oppress women. So, yes, exactly, that's,
and that's how it spread. When Europe went everywhere,
they brought all their systems with them.
Yeah, just to comment on one of the things
you mentioned there, yeah, I mean, funnily enough, it
seems that as intelligent as many of those men
who were the philosophers and the law writers and
the politicians and the artists and the fiction writers
and all of that, as intelligent as they might
have been. I mean, if you are in a
position of privilege in your society, you tend to
write or to elaborate arguments, many of them post
hoc rationalizations, even if you create an entire complex
philosophical system around it to justify the social. Order,
the position you have, the privileges you have, and
all that comes with it.
Oh, exactly. And you can see that, like, really,
it's really interesting to look at, like, early Christian
church fathers, um, and how they had studied the
Greeks, right? They had studied extremely misogynistic teachings of
Aristotle and, and many of the Greek thinkers. And
they had also inherited the Hebrew Bible. And so,
all of the The thinking of the Hebrews and
the Greeks, and then to your point exactly, kind
of retroactively justifying why those made sense. They just
take the foundations for granted, and then they build
another layer on top of those foundations. So as
the early Christian church is forming, It's not forming
in a vacuum. They are inheriting all of those
foundational teachings from the men before them who had
written and, and come up with their ideas about
what gender meant, and that gets encoded in our
religious systems, and we still feel it today, from
those very, its brilliant, um, scholarly men, and they're,
you know, not a single woman in the room,
not a single woman thinker, and I'll say this
too, this is one of the, something that really
resonated with my personal experience, and I think is
very, very common. Um, I, I was very influenced
by Gerda Lerner. She's a, uh, an American scholar
who was writing in the 1980s, and she said
that men have always benefited from, uh, because of,
because of education, because of access to education, they
always knew what the people before them had thought
and taught, right? The, the, the knowledge that was
discovered and created was passed down in writing. To
the next generation, and men got to, to build
upon and supersede. That which was discovered by their
ancestors. So, that's what men had access to. Women,
because they didn't have access to education, and specifically
because they didn't have access to women's history, have
been doomed generation after generation to reinvent the wheel.
We didn't know, I did not know, as I
was, like, feeling the pain points of patriarchy in
my life, I would just feel like I was
the first one. I, I didn't know anybody else
had ever had ever struggled with that. I was
made to feel in my specifically in my religious
context that there was something wrong with me, that
I was bad, that I was weird, like, why
was I feeling that way? And when I finally
started studying women's history, I saw that women had
been Identifying these problems, coming up with brilliant critiques,
and fighting against them, literally for hundreds of years.
And I was having to reinvent the wheel, thinking
I was the very first one, because I wasn't
able to benefit from the knowledge that had been
produced by my foremothers. So, that's, that's actually why
I do the work that I do, cause I
thought, I don't want this to keep happening. Women
need to know about the systems we've inherited, and
that This has all been thought of before, it's
just not taught in schools, and if people don't
know the history, they're just doomed to try to
come up with. Um, WITH solutions on their own
instead of benefiting from all of the stuff that's
already been discovered and thought of. So anyway.
By, by the way, in terms of the spread
of patriarchy across the world, and this is very
interesting because as you said, since you were raised
religious, do you look at religion generally as something
that helped spread patriarchy across the world as well,
or do you think that Perhaps that is more
limited to maybe the Abrahamic religions which are the
dominant ones nowadays, and with Christianity, for example, it
was a vehicle also for European colonialism and things
like that or I mean, I mean because I'm
asking you this because I'm an atheist and I've
been an atheist for a very long time. I
mean up till I was 22, 23, I was
one of those I I mean, very irritating militant
atheists, but in the meanwhile I learned a lot
of anthropology and left that bit behind and so
on. Nowadays I understand more religion as more of
a universal social phenomenon in human societies, but, but,
but I mean I struggle to really condemn just
religion in general because over history we've also had
very important And movements with which religious people are
associated and some of them spearheaded by religious people.
In, for example, the 19th century, some abolitionists were
religious, the Quakers, for example, in the 1960s we've
had religious people associated, associated with the civic movements,
people like Martin Luther King and Anti-colonialist people like
Gandhi and all of that, so I mean, I
find it really hard to just, I mean, just
say, OK, religion as a blanket statement is bad
and religion generally helps spread patriarchy and other bad
things across the world. I think that, I mean,
maybe it's more intellectually honest and also more fair
for us to be more specific in. In terms
of our criticisms of religion in those regards.
That's exactly how I feel about it. It, I
don't, I agree completely that it isn't intellectually honest
or mature to, to categorize something that's so complex
and complicated with any black and white. Exactly to
your point that even just taking the Bible, Um,
that there are oppressive parts of the Bible and
liberatory parts of the Bible. And exactly to your
point, I, I was thinking of the exact two
things that you mentioned in the United States, which,
which is the abolitionist movement, wasn't just associated with
the Bible, it came out of the liberatory doctrine
of, of, of Christ, of the figure of Jesus
Christ, and Um, and same thing for the civil
rights movement, that was born out of, you know,
the story of Exodus and, and the people leaving
slavery, and that God would eventually come and help
them, um, escape and, and, uh, from slavery, and
that I think without that hope and without that
spiritual anchor, I don't, I don't know if it
would have been able to happen, and, and many
of my black friends still are very, very involved
in their Christian churches. And they, it, the, the
Christian church was a vehicle for social justice, and,
um, and, and a very liberating force in their
lives, and still is, actually. So, I agree. I
mean, the, the Bible itself contains it kind of
anything you want to find in it, you can
find in it and justify what you're going to
do with it, but Well, I would say, I,
and I'm still a very spiritual person and find
a great deal of beauty in all the world's
religions and, and danger there also, so we just
have to be discerning and good critical thinkers as
we're looking at any of those things.
Uh, AND what do you make of, uh, capitalism
specifically? I mean, because I, I can't, uh, maybe
I have a sort of bias here because I'm
socialist, but at the same time, I think even
putting the socialist bit aside, I think that it's
pretty obvious or if not obvious, pretty well supported
by the historical evidence that Capitalism has always been
also very much associated with the spread of patriarchy
and even if you want to also add a
classist ingredient to it and even from a global
perspective, you can include the fact that from the
very inception capitalism was very much associated with slavery,
with exploiting people. From the colonized areas, people from
what nowadays we call the global South, which is
still very much true even nowadays that those people
are exploited in different ways to serve the interests
or to facilitate the life of people who live
in more developed industrialized countries and so I mean
I can't avoid just looking. Can get capitalism is
also one part of the equation here in terms
of more broad exploitation of peoples across the world
and also women specifically also because capitalism, at least
at the very least up until the 19th century
was also very much emphasizing gender roles if I,
if I'm not mistaken about that.
Yeah, you're absolutely right, and this is one thing
that I struggle with, um, just full disclosure, I,
my husband is an entrepreneur. He started a company
with You know, just having a, a college job
and getting a little money, a little capital, and
then started a company that he's just worked and
worked and worked and grown and grown and grown,
and it's gotten to be a really big company,
and that has supported our family. I haven't, I
didn't work outside the home while I was raising
our children, and so, Um, we've benefited from the,
the capitalist system where literally we used a little
bit of capital and made it grow. And we,
I mean, as a couple now, are, are really,
um, Trying to reckon with unchecked capitalism and the
fact that, that we've seen, as he's continued to
be CEO of this company, that the way the
system works is that just the disproportionate benefiting of
him and the executives of the company. And it's,
it is truly an exploitative system, but it is
one that we've benefited from so much that it
is something we, we actually talk about it daily
and have cried tears about it, and also really
done everything we can to just on our own
redistribute things in a way that feels more fair
to the employees at his company, and I'm really,
really proud of what he's done personally. But there's
no systemic requirement that anybody does that, that anybody
does make it more fair. So, uh, that's, I
just wanted to, you know, in full disclosure, kind
of say that at the outset. I will say
yes, I mean, capitalism has been intertwined with patriarchy
from the very beginning. If we're talking about like
capitalist oppression, like benefiting from people's work, That's like
the nuclear patriarchal family, like the, the man is
benefiting from women's invisible free labor. The whole, our
whole society has been benefiting from women's invisible free
labor, and so it makes a lot of sense
that people would talk about almost like a, a
direct parallel of like the man as the bourgeoisie,
and he's benefiting from the labor of the woman
who's just like, Simone de Beauvoir and the Second
Sex talks about it and she uses the word
imminence, that it's like the hamster wheel, having babies,
caring for babies, making food, cleaning up the food,
cleaning the house, and she's just running on that
hamster wheel for free, while he gets to transcend
and kind of achieve his, his potential. So, yes,
there are definitely parallels, that are definitely tied together.
Um, IF I can just share another kind of,
uh, um, an anecdote of the way that this
is happening ongoing in our culture, and it, it's
a critique of the kind of the girl boss,
um, and in kind of in, I would say
even like the last I would say maybe 10
years ago, I really started to see this really
clearly, where white women, specifically, um, were, you know,
like, I'm going to be empowered, and I'm gonna
start a company, and I can do it all,
right? And I can be a mom, and I
can have a company, and that's, that's actually great,
but what would happen is that these, you know,
these families, this white woman who wanted to be
a girl boss and wanted to break the glass
ceiling, would realize, well, in order for me to
get this done and be a mom at the
same time, I need help and so I need
to bring in, you know, like somebody has to
take care of the kids, somebody has to
they, they would be outsourcing the domestic labor to
women that are usually not always but usually part
of minorities in the US, for example, Hispanic women,
black women.
Exactly. And, and, and paying them the least amount
that they can get away with, not providing healthcare,
not providing. So what's that woman who's coming in
and helping you be a girl boss? What does
she do when her kids are sick? Right? And
so, you know, how is she going to get
ahead? How is she going to be an entrepreneur
and get ahead in this capitalist system? So, I
do understand the critique that, like, capitalism has to
be dismantled in order for all women to be
able to achieve, um, equality. You, you can't. You
can't exploit other women and call yourself, you know,
a good feminist, and, and that continues to happen,
and I'm just, just, I'm really discouraged to see
people still not be awake to that. Um, IT,
people just kind of are, are still charging ahead
and not seeing the, the class critique that, that
I think is so critical in order to lift
up everybody.
But, uh, by the way, in regards to patriarchy,
uh, many people have this, uh, erroneous idea that,
uh, OK, so if we are feminists and we
are critiquing or blaming the patriarchy for different societal
issues, we're saying that it only affects women. But
actually, that's not the case. It can also affect
men, right? So, uh, in what ways, or could
you give us perhaps some clear examples of how
it affects men as well?
Yeah, 100%, yeah, if we're talking about kind of
the traditional, um, the traditional gender division of labor
in the home, where until recently, and in my
community still ongoing, that men Um, were the, were
the breadwinners and the ones who were working outside
the home to bring in money, and women were
at home, um, taking care of the children. That
actually has a downside for everybody. If we look
at, for example, like, I don't know if you're
familiar with the Harvard study of happiness and human
thriving, it's, it's a longitudinal study out of Harvard
that's been going on for decades, just to see,
like, what makes people happy on their deathbeds, what
do they say? Um, THEIR regrets.
Yeah, I, I, I, I think that I read
some things about it, yeah. Yeah.
Well, what people say is, you would probably be
able to guess, is the things that make people
happy are relationships, healthy relationships with other people, and
doing something that they feel mattered, like realizing their
human potential and making a contribution, right? That makes
people happy. It creates creates flourishing regardless of gender.
So yeah,
but basically you will never find anyone on their
deathbed saying, oh, I should have worked more, or
I should have made more money.
Exactly, exactly, yes, and so people, that's the way
I see it, and you think of, you know,
Maslow's hierarchies of hierarchy of needs, same thing, like
self-actualization, like, I achieved my human potential, my individual
potential, and I had good relationships, right? I have
healthy relationships. So what This, this gendered patriarchal division
of labor does is it keeping women out of
the workforce makes it so women. Um, ONE thing
that that does is creates dependence on men, which
isn't good, and it also has historically limited women's
ability to achieve their potential, to make a contribution
in the adult world, maybe as a doctor, or
as a teacher, or as an artist or whatever,
cause it keeps her in that hamster wheel. So
it, that's one way that it's harmed women, but
what we don't talk about as much, or we're
just barely starting to talk about, is that it's
kept men, historically, from having those deep relationships. One
thing that women have been able to have in
the home is relationship with their children, and the
joy that comes from parenting, relationship with other people.
You have groups of women friends that are able
to share and support each other. And one thing
that I see men have missed out on, and
I have had men literally cry to me about
this, that their kids grew up. And they were
really kind of slaving away at the office, at
trying to bring money home, and their kids grew
up and they didn't spend time with their kids,
or that they don't have friends, that they haven't
been, they haven't been taught how to make friends,
how to invest in relationships. And so, that's one
way that I see these patriarchal gender roles having
really harmed men is emotionally stunting them in some
ways. And also, Precluding them just by their schedules,
that they're working so hard, trying to be a
good man, trying to support their family and provide
for their family, that they're not, they have not
been able to invest in those relationships that humans
need for flourishing. That's one thing. And that, that
emotional piece too, and this is getting better, but,
you know, the, the whole thing about, like, boys
don't cry, real men don't show. Don't show vulnerability,
they don't show weakness, that's incredibly damaging to men's
emotional health and, and to their ability to, to
create relationships. Those are a couple of things that
I think of.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, and, and I, uh, I want
to link it now to, uh, the manosphere because
that's a very, a very widespread phenomenon right now,
particularly on the internet, and it has been so
for the past, I don't know, 1015 years or
so. So, uh, what do you make of it?
Where do you think that it stems from? Are
there particular, I don't know, factors that you see
might have played the biggest role in the uh
rise and spread of the manosphere?
I'm learning about it. I, I mean, I, you'll
probably have a guest on, on your podcast that,
that would know more about it than I do,
but I would say just in general, the, the,
um, It can be encapsulated in the phrase that
for people accustomed to privilege, equality feels like oppression.
And so, I think we're going through the growing
pains of transition, where men are realizing that, you
know, that women are, you know, as women, Do
fill more spots in education and in leadership, if
they have the assumption of, you know, that they
have this birthright of a spot at the table,
that they have this expectation that they're going to
be the leaders for a woman to join and
say, no, actually, I, I got that spot. I
was qualified and I got it. That men will
lose their minds because they have this expectation that,
that that is their role, that that's their birthright.
And so, it feels like oppression to them to
have equality, and I guess I, I would just
say like, yeah, that, that's hard, and you're going
to have to grow up and figure that out,
and also figure out that, that, um, Your life
will be the most satisfying to you and the
most, you know, the most flourishing life by achieving
your individual potential, and that you have power to
achieve the life you want. You don't need power
over other people. Power equals you being the kind
of person you want to be. It doesn't require
power over others, but if you're taught that it
does require power over others, then you're gonna be
pretty disappointed, and then start to resent. The people
that you see coming in and, and taking what
you thought was yours. Um, BUT it's, it's really
scary to me. I mean, as it is to
all of us, I guess, just to see the
rise of these Andrew Tits and these extremely influential
people, um, telling young men that the way, yeah,
the way to have power is to have power
over others. It's just, it's a lie. It doesn't
make men happier, and it's, it's terrifying for everybody.
Yeah, I'm going to tell you about an idea.
I won't even call it a hypothesis not to
use because I don't want to use the scientific
term here because it's not even a proper, I
think, scientific hypothesis, but an idea I have about.
What's behind the manosphere and at least I'm not
focusing here on the influencers themselves because I think
that those are pretty much exploiting the insecurities of
men across the world and there are difficult circumstances,
but I think that what really attracts many men
out there, particularly young men, to the manosphere, has
to do with the fact that we are now.
Living and since the 2010s, which was around the
time where social media started proliferating and then the
manosphere also started proliferating, as very much to do
with the fact that we live in times since
the 2008 economic crisis where the labor market has
become increasingly unstable. Economic conditions for people have become
increasingly unstable, and I mean in the Particular case
of men, adding to that the cultural aspect of
imbuing them with the idea of traditional generals, and
they have to be the breadwinner, they have to
be the provider and all of that. I mean,
since in the current economic circumstances for the vast
majority of people, it's just not possible to do
that for one single person in this case, one
single man. To provide for a household, an entire
family, or even just his partner alone. So I
think that because of that, because of the economic
circumstances and tied with the ideas that men have
to to fulfill those particular roles, there, there's been
for the past almost 20 years an increasing number
of men that feel disenfranchised. THAT feel that they
have no direction or purpose in life, that they
look at the future and it seems hopeless because
they don't have any economic prospects or relationship prospects
and all of that. And then these figures come
on the scene and they ride the wave of
the spread of social media and people were getting
more and more connected to the internet and then
they present these simplistic. Narratives of scapegoating women, scapegoating
minorities, scapegoating vulnerable people, and saying, OK, so if
you're in this situation, it's it's these people's fault,
it's the fault of the feminists, the fault of,
I don't know, sometimes they even include leftist people
in in that sort of narrative, and basically, OK,
it's not. It's not a problem with the system
itself. Actually they push for the system because, oh,
you have to become more muscular. You have to
work harder and longer hours, and I mean at
the end of the day, in the current circumstances
that just simply doesn't work and then men keep
coming back to the manosphere for more and more
answers and also, I mean, And this is a
critique of my side as well. I mean, people
on the left, very unfortunately, I think that sometimes
people have not really paid enough attention to the
struggles of men in. In society, I mean, and,
and then these menosphere figures appear and at least
they validate their struggles, their worries, their complaints, and
all of the difficulties they're going through. So I
don't know what you think about
that. I totally agree with that, and I do,
I do think that's one of the reasons that,
that is one of the reasons that I do
think we need to take men's. Take men seriously,
and, and like I was saying before, like, some
of the, when I encounter feminists that I disagree
with, it's often on this issue, that they have,
they've been so hurt, I think, by men, and
that's the reason, that they become really angry and
really dismissive, and like, I don't care that men
are struggling, men need to figure it out themselves.
I can't be the one to figure that out
for them. That's fine, that's, that's fair, maybe, that
women feel exhausted of doing all the emotional labor
of like, and now I have to not only,
you know, figure things out and how I'm going
to survive within patriarchy, but now I have to
also figure out how to help men feel better.
They are the ones that have already always benefited.
I, I tend to, I guess I just, I
have the bandwidth for it, and I have the
heart for it, and I do think, um, I
think the only way forward is to Listen and
hear what they're actually saying and care. I do
care. I have a son, I have a brother,
I have male friends. I care very much that
the future we're we're building is a, a fair
and nurturing world for boys also, as well as
girls. I care about the whole human family, and
the fact that men are struggling and are in
mental health crisis. I do think I do take
it very seriously, and I care genuinely, and I,
and, and also I do think strategically it is
wise, because young men, especially who are, who do
have hurt, and they, if they get the message,
we don't care about you, of course, they're going
to go find a community that they feel does
care about them and does make them feel like
they matter, and gives, and, and Then we're losing
them to extremists. So
and also it's doubly dangerous because those men are
also young, young disenfranchised men are the ones we
typically see participating in school shootings, participating in other
kinds of public. Violence because it's like, oh, I
don't have anything to lose, so whatever, I'm just
going to blow myself up and take some people
with me because I'm just sick and tired of
this society. Nobody cares about me, so whatever.
Yeah, I agree. I, I do care about them.
I think as a society we do need to
care about all the members of our society and,
and try to come up with solutions together.
Yeah, yeah, so I mean, let me ask you
this, of course we've already, with all of this,
we've already alluded to the ways that boys and
men can also benefit from feminism, but can boys
and men be feminists themselves? I mean, I'm asking
you this for a very particular reason. It's because
there was this one instance where I heard from
a radical feminist and very specifically a gender critical
feminist that I couldn't be a feminist because I'm
a man and men generally can't be feminists, that
at best they can be allies because I mean
men don't have the kind of social experiences that
women go through for because They are women and
so they don't have the same understanding of women's
struggles as they have and so I mean, which
for me is just sounds very silly because actually
I mean it's not that we are two different
species, right? I mean, most of the experiences that
women have, men also have psychologically and all of
that, but also, I mean, we're not. Devoid of
empathy and so we can understand that people who
go through particular kinds of struggles, how they might
feel and why it's a struggle for them and
empathize with that. I mean, so it just seems
silly to me, but what do you think about
that?
Yeah, it seems silly to me too, and actually
really unfortunate. I really disagree with that person. And
I've actually never heard that before, and I know
a lot of feminists, and I've never heard anyone
say that, but I, I believe you, and there
are, I mean, I've read things that I think,
oh wow, I, yeah, very strongly disagree with that.
I mean, if you, if we just go back,
that's why I think dictionary definitions are useful. We
can just agree on the definition that it's that
feminism is the effort toward um gender equity. And
we actually need men and boys on board in
the mission toward gender equity. Men are, there are
many, um, you know, positions of power that only
men occupy. Like I said, in the United States,
we've never had a female president yet, and the
president has a lot of power. We need a
feminist. President, even as a man, to have the
influence and to have access to those, those levers,
um, and so it's absolutely critical to have boys
and men and people of all genders on board.
Women actually can't do it all by ourselves. So,
yeah, yeah, so, uh, I, I'm seeing that we're
reaching our time limit. So just one final question,
and I mean, do you think that there's enough
room in feminism. To perhaps push for um a
view that is more reconciliatory in terms of trying
to reconcile both genders. I mean, because we've been
talking here about, for example, uh, patriarchy and how
women for the vast majority of human history, at
least in the more sedentary societies have been subjugated
to men in different ways. And for the most
part men were the ones who held the positions
of power and all of that. So of course
it's perfectly understandable that many women feminists really, I
mean, really have this attitude of blaming men more
generally for what women went through throughout most of
our. History and all of that and then as
we talked about just a couple of minutes ago
about the men sphere and the current economic and
political conditions, the struggles that men go through, and
then when they hear that, I mean, it's they
themselves alone as they hear for and very unfortunately
for from certain feminists that have to work on
themselves. I mean, and they have to do it
alone, which I think is also very unfair. Fair
because people shouldn't exist in society and to try
to overcome their struggles alone. That's not the kind
of species we are. We are a social species.
That's not the kind of social circumstances we've evolved
in. I mean, the kind of loneliness and atomization
in society that we see nowadays is just historically
unprecedented even in agricultural societies. It wasn't like that
at all. And So, but I mean, I'm just
mentioning that to say that of course it's also
understandable, at least to some extent that some men
out there would be, um, I mean, would resent
feminism and people who label themselves as feminists, but
do you think that there's space in feminism to
try to reconcile the genders and not just try
to push in one direction or the other?
Well, that's exactly the space I choose to occupy
within feminism. Again, as an educator, as a bridge
builder, as a person who believes that love is
the power that heals people, that we have to
heal in community with each other, as you just
said, as human beings, that's just the way we
work, and seeing Other, um, other areas where healing
has happened after war, for example, from truth and
reconciliation efforts, from real, um, kind of penitence, and
then forgiveness, like we, we See this in a
lot of areas where a group of humans has
caused terrible harm to another group of humans, and
you, and, you know, what do we do now?
You, I think it's important to recognize how you
got to the place you are, which is what
I do as a historian, is like, here's how
we got here. Here's what we inherited, and now,
what do we want? What do we want to
pass along to our children? If we want it
to be something better than we inherited, then we
have hard work to do. We have hard conversations
to have in our, you know, individual lives with
the people we know. We have hard work to
do, you know, kind of more removed politically, and
like I said, and if we have a religious
community, in our workplaces, in our schools, in all
these different areas, I just think the only way
to do that is to be real about how
we got here. I, I understand it's a hard
ask of men, but I do think I've, I've
seen real healing happen when men are able to
sit with the harm. A lot of times men,
um, do get, even really, really good men, even
men I love a lot, they do tend to
get defensive and say, like, well, I didn't do
that. I would never do that. Um, IF men
can do this work and say, and just, like,
kind of calm their defensiveness down and just listen
to the harm that has happened to probably all
the women in their lives, and realize, like, maybe
we're not saying you specifically are to blame, but
make space for women to be able to, to
express how it's felt to them. That can be
extremely healing. And then I think Work that I
encourage women to do is to, as much as
we can, not blame the, you know, the men
in our lives for things that they didn't do,
because that does create more division and it does
create more defensiveness. So, it requires a lot of
skill in, in having these, um, repair conversations between
the genders. It's very difficult, but I think if
we can approach it with the genuine desire to
understand. And then the genuine desire to, to do
the hard work of forgiveness, um, and moving forward.
I wish there were an easier answer, but I
don't know that there is one. I just think
it's gonna require people to kind of swallow their
pride. And, and see if we can, see if
we can, yeah, repair what our ancestors caused, so
that we don't hand it on to our kids.
Yeah, so let's end on that great note, Amy,
and uh apart from your podcast and of course
your YouTube channel, which, as I already said, will
be linked in the description below, uh, where can
people find you on the internet?
Yeah, thanks. Just at our Instagram is at Bown
patriarchy, just because breaking down patriarchy was too long.
So, yeah, if you just look up Breaking Down
Patriarchy, as you said, the podcast and the YouTube
channel and Instagram, I would also say, let me
throw in one more thing, um, that's really useful
about the podcast, is just the reading list alone,
because this is one thing that really helps in
the process of repair that we just talked about,
for women to not have to have the conversations
over and over and over and over again. People
have written amazing, brilliant books, and my podcast goes
through. Basically, it's like a free graduate school level,
um, educational project, so you can, like, get the
TLDR of, like, you don't have time to read
The Second Sex by Simone de Beauvair, for, for
example, cause it's this big. But you can get
the TLDR and the discussion of it and benefit
from all of the scholars who have done this
work to educate yourself. So, listen to the podcast,
watch the YouTube channel, but then also go to
the website and just look at the reading list
if you're interested in actually reading some of those
books, or just listen to our conversations about those
books. That's a really great way to, um, educate
yourself and then make a difference.
OK, great. So look, it's been really awesome to
have you on the show and to talk with
you. I've been a very big fan of your
podcast and your YouTube channel for a while now,
and you're, I mean, in the YouTube space, you,
together with Trizzly are my two favorite feminists there,
so it's been really an honor, and I mean,
if you're open to it, I would really love
to have you back on the show somewhere in
the future.
I would love to. This has been just a
joy. Thank you so much, Ricardo.
Hi guys, thank you for watching this interview until
the end. If you liked it, please share it,
leave a like and hit the subscription button. The
show is brought to you by Enlights Learning and
Development done differently. Check their website at enlights.com and
also please consider supporting the show on Patreon or
PayPal. I would also like to give a huge
thank you to my main patrons and PayPal supporters,
Perergo Larsson, Jerry Muller, Frederick Sundo, Bernard Seyaz Olaf,
Alex, Adam Cassel, Matthew Whittingbird, Arnaud Wolff, Tim Hollis,
Eric Elena, John Connors, Philip Forrest Connolly. Then Dmitri
Robert Windegeru Inasi Zu Mark Nevs, Colin Holbrookfield, Governor,
Michel Stormir, Samuel Andrea, Francis Forti Agnun, Svergoo, and
Hal Herz Agnon, Michel Jonathan Labran, John Yardston, and
Samuel Curric Hines, Mark Smith, John Ware, Tom Hammel,
Sardusran, David Sloan Wilson, Yasilla Dezaraujo Romain Roach, Diego
Londono Correa. Yannik Puntervan Ruzmani, Charlotte Blis Nicole Barbaro,
Adam Hunt, Pavlostazevski, Alekbaka, Madison, Gary G. Alman, Semov,
Zal Adrian Yei Poltontin, John Barboza, Julian Price, Edward
Hall, Edin Bronner, Douglas Fry, Franco Bartolati, Gabriel P
Scortez or Suliliski, Scott Zachary Fish, Tim Duffy, Sony
Smith, and Wiseman. Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Georg
Jarno, Luke Lovai, Georgios Theophanous, Chris Williamson, Peter Wolozin,
David Williams, Di Acosta, Anton Ericsson, Charles Murray, Alex
Shaw, Marie Martinez, Coralli Chevalier, Bangalore atheists, Larry D.
Lee Junior. Old Eringbon. Esterri, Michael Bailey, then Spurber,
Robert Grassy, Zigoren, Jeff McMahon, Jake Zul, Barnabas Raddix,
Mark Kempel, Thomas Dovner, Luke Neeson, Chris Story, Kimberly
Johnson, Benjamin Galbert, Jessica Nowicki, Linda Brendan, Nicholas Carlson,
Ismael Bensleyman. George Ekoriati, Valentine Steinmann, Per Crawley, Kate
Van Goler, Alexander Obert, Liam Dunaway, BR, Massoud Ali
Mohammadi, Perpendicular, Jannes Hetner, Ursula Guinov, Gregory Hastings, David
Pinsov, Sean Nelson, Mike Levin, and Jos Necht. A
special thanks to my producers Iar Webb, Jim Frank,
Lucas Stink, Tom Vanneden, Bernardine Curtis Dixon, Benedict Mueller,
Thomas Trumbull, Catherine and Patrick Tobin, John Carlo Montenegro,
Al Nick Cortiz, and Nick Golden, and to my
executive producers, Matthew Lavender, Sergio Quadrian, Bogdan Kanis, and
Rosie. Thank you for all.